what's gonna fulfill you is differently
at first next you're not gonna learn
that from anybody else you got to find
it because success without fulfilment is
the ultimate failure forty percent of
all jobs they project in the next ten
years are going to disappear because of
technology I'm a believer that talking
is both that you got to go deep you got
to get people to experience things I
think a belief is a poor substitute for
an experienced need motivation watch it
top ten with believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
growing up in a chaotic and abusive
household to leaving home at age 17 to
become a janitor to becoming a
best-selling author world renowned life
coach and entrepreneur he's Tony Robbins
and here's my take on his top 50 rules
for success also if you want to know
what Tony and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my to
54 confident series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the fact that
human beings are strongest drive is the
need to stay consistent with how we
define ourselves so while you're in this
passionate state that's where you make
decisions so if you want to change your
life my friends you've got to change
your physiology and you got to change
your focus
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one raise your standards ultimately if
you're gonna have lasting change in
anything you're really talking about
just raising your standards I mean I
always tell people if you want to know
how to change your life and give it to
you in three words boring as it sounds
raise your standards and what does that
mean corny as it sounds raise your
standards I'll thank you for the
breakthrough thought Tony I'm glad I
wasted my time watching this little
email with you but think about it
lasting change is different than a goal
you don't always get your goals but you
always get your standards maybe it'll
help you is to think about it this way I
try to explain standards to people with
a different set of words think of it as
everybody in life gets their must they
don't get their shoulds right think
about it
you must be above a list of shoulds nope
they don't you have a list of the
shoulds things you should do you should
follow through on I I should lose some
weight I should work out more I should
make more calls I should respond more
rapidly to my email whatever you know I
should get into the office earlier I
should be you know more confident
whatever your should list is people love
to have their should list make the net
but it's kind of like New Year's
resolutions if it does it's really
exciting but if it doesn't which is most
the time it's a little disappointing but
you kind of know it's not gonna happen
but when you decide something as a must
for you and absolute must when you cut
up any possible you say I'm gonna find
the way I'm gonna make the way human
beings when they resolve things and they
have make a real resolution inside
themselves which is they raise the
standard they make it a must they find
the way think about it your own life
happens you had some area of your life
where you raise your standard in your
life has never been the same maybe at
one time your life you use smoke
cigarettes or you did something and you
did it for years and you kept trying to
change it trying to change it and kept
telling yourself I should and then one
day something happened something just
clicked you over something took you over
that kind of tipping point and inside
yourself you said no more there was a
very very different experience wasn't it
something inside you shifted and what
was a should became a must and you've
never gone back is there an area like
that in your life you could think of
I ever smoked cigarettes did you ever
eat a certain way drink a certain form
of alcohol and then finally saying no
morn you just don't go back and notice
this it doesn't really take any
willpower anymore because somewhere when
we make this click we make something a
must we attach ourselves to it it
becomes part of our identity the one
thing I've learned in the last gosh 33
years are working people from now over
100 countries 4 million people is human
beings absolutely follow through on who
they believe they are if you said to me
well I'm really gonna work hard to stop
smoking but you know I've been a smoker
my whole life and I'm you know I am a
smoker I know your days are numbered
you're gonna be back smoking cigarettes
again because we all act consistent with
who we believe we are
I tell people the strongest force in the
whole human personality is this need to
stay consistent with how we define
ourselves
if you define yourself as somebody who
is really conservative you're not gonna
be crazy and act nuts unless you're
really drunk or something and then you
can say it's the alcohol when it really
does you finally getting permission to
be yourself the alcohol is your excuse
if you're a really crazy person you act
crazy outrageous playful you don't have
conservative because that's not who you
are Bern often people say well I can't
do that I'm not that kind of person and
I always say to people really when did
you define yourself I mean really how
many years ago did you come up with what
you could and couldn't do in your life I
don't know years ago most people if they
really look at how they're living their
life today it's based on a set of
standards a set of beliefs that they
made choices about 10 20 30 or more
years ago I mean very often we made
decisions in our youth or very young
about what to believe about what we were
capable of about who we are as a person
and that becomes the glass ceiling a few
well that controls us there's a corny
metaphor but it's true I remember one
time I was with my family at the circus
and there's a person there and they had
this big giant elephant and you look at
this elephant and they take this little
rope put it around the Hoffmans neck and
they drive the stake into the ground and
I mean you look at this you know that
elephant could rip down the entire tent
with almost no F
and yet the elephant doesn't struggle
doesn't try why because the elephant's
conditioned and they take that elephant
conditioned the elephant when it's a
baby elephant that's how they train them
when it's a little baby elephant it
doesn't have the power yet they put a
big rope around it and they drive this
huge stake in the ground and your
elephant fights and fights and fights
and one day finally that often decides
I'm not capable Alling this out and once
that becomes the definition of an
identity of anyone an elephant in this
case they don't even try anymore it's
just who I am that's how it is that's
just the way it is in my life I'd like
to ask you to take a look at any place
you've got a limitation ask yourself
when did I decide to accept that
limitation and you may not even see it
as a limitation you might see that just
that's who I am
but so often in our lives we've adapted
to be a certain way so that we don't
fail or so that people will like us or
respect us but it's not necessarily who
we are joy comes when you're spontaneous
it's really hard to be truly happy when
you're not being yourself and most of us
have no clue who we are and so a big
part of my work if you've ever been to
an event you know is to get people to do
things spontaneously without thinking
because that's when the real you shows
up that's when the energy comes alive
and when you do that when you start to
connect your true nature suddenly
there's energy available for you to set
a higher standard for what you want in
your life that's what this is really all
about and when I talk about standards
when I talk about you know shoulds
versus must think about your own life I
know there have been areas in your life
where some point in time you just shift
it and you raise the standard in your
life change because whatever people have
their identity attached to they live we
live who we believe we are that's just
how it works it's just kind of like I
give an example look at your physical
body your physical body today is an
absolute reflection of only one thing
not your goals not your desires but your
standards the identity you have for
yourself if your standard is you're an
athlete then there's a certain amount of
strength a muscle tone and energy that's
available in your body on a regular
basis because that's who you are and so
you do whatever's necessary
sorry to maintain that identity again
the strongest force and the human
personalities this need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
because if you don't know who you are
you would not act once you lock in on
that identity your brain finds a way to
keep you there if you say you know man
I'm overweight I've always been
overweight I'm big-boned and that's the
story you've got and you're gonna always
find a way to get back there that's
you're settling point that's your
identity that's where things walk in if
you see somebody who's a really great
shape you ask him do you work out you
know the answer yes how often and
they'll tell you three times four times
five times a week whatever in a seminar
last people who here works out at least
five days a week and I'm stand-up and
you look around that room and you know
that they work out five times a week as
you can see their body you don't just
get a result without some kind of action
without some form of ritual ritual
meaning actions you do consistently now
do you think you knows people that are
out there working out five days a week
do they have more time than you do or I
have for anybody else of course not
is that a wife less busy of course not
it's just a must for them they must work
out that way and they've made that turn
their life changed so I'm not saying you
have to work out five days a week
I'm just saying whatever you really want
once don't get met consistently
standards do whatever you identify this
is Who I am and so it's not so much
about changing your identity as there's
expanding it you know deciding that you
know instead of your goals to lose ten
pounds which is not compelling what if
your vision was to get back to my
fighting weight you know this this year
this month this next 90 days I'm gonna
transform my body I'm gonna take on a
new challenge I'm gonna find some
technique or strategy there's a million
of them that can reframe myself where I
want to feel younger stronger more
vibrant than ever before here's my
reasons because I want the energy to
really make my life work because it's
tough out there and I want to be
stronger than I've ever been before I
don't go in front of the mirror if I'm
naked not you know want to laugh I won't
look there and take a good look and go
yeah
I'm proud of whatever I see there
whatever it takes someone's gonna make
you laugh smile
someone's gonna tease yourself but
someone's gonna move you to another
level if you identify yourself in a new
way and you own that every day and that
becomes the staredown you live you'll
find the way to make that standard real
money's the same way I think about it
doesn't matter what's happening
quote-unquote in the marketplace people
that make money find a way to make money
no matter what don't they I mean most
people's standard is to pay their bills
so that's what most people find a way to
do even when economic times get tough
most people if that's their absolute
standard they find a way some people's
standard is pay their bills and most of
the time and so most the time they do
some people's standard is not just to
pay their bills but to take care of
their family and maybe even some of
their friends and they find a way in
fact you know if some people may be in a
family where they don't have enough
money to barely have money to pay their
bills they work through guts out and
then somebody their mother their father
somebody else their sister gets ill and
there's not enough money to take care of
it nobody else has money and family they
don't either but they find a way to get
that money to take care of their mother
or father don't they and they their
bells they never could do it before why
the situation made them raise their own
standard and not everybody does that
somebody else in the family might have
money and still don't take care of their
mother it all comes down to the inner
game my friends changing your life is a
change in the inner game the outside
world you can't control but you have
absolute control over this one if you
learn that dynamics of what shapes you
and identity is one of those simple
clear fundamental basics that if you
start to shift it everything else will
shift in your life as well some people
by the way have to have more than enough
money to do what they want when they
want where they want with whomever they
want contribute the way they want if
that's there must they find a way I know
that sounds overly simplistic but it's
true now somebody once said you can take
all the money in the world out of the
hands of everybody out of all the
wealthy people in the world who are
really successful give it to other
people it wouldn't take too long those
people have it back in their hands it's
not because they're manipulators because
they have a standard some are manipular
don't get me wrong but they've got a
standard of what they're gonna find a
way to make happen
simply saying to you take those three
magic words and live them raise your
standard rule number two be truly
fulfilled Michael Gerber the guy who
wrote the e-myth you know talks about
why so many businesses young businesses
fail and one of these things he says is
most people are not really entrepreneurs
but they think that's what they should
be they think that's the sexy thing
that's the most attractive thing that's
the best answer and what I say to you is
you've got to separate the vehicle from
the outcome what is it that's gonna
truly fulfill you what is it that's
gonna give you that extraordinary life
what's gonna make things magnificent on
your terms not somebody else's terms not
your father your mother your background
what is that really separate the
vehicles there's many ways to get to
that vehicle what I'm saying sometimes
you got to re-evaluate what's gonna
really make you fulfill what is your
gift are you an artist are you the
talent can produce something no one else
produces as a skill or a product or a
service or some impact are you
incredibly good at management you really
know how to manage or lead people are
you an extraordinary entrepreneur that
has can take that gigantic gut load of
risk and can create the vision and
attract the talent that you need and the
managers and leaders you may have all
three abilities but which one really
fulfills you the most is going to be the
critical question because we tend to
want to do them all especially room like
this because you're all overachievers
right me too and you say well I can do
all these yes you can but what will it
do to your quality of life see again the
secrets gonna be this what is an
extraordinary life on your terms today
rule number three progress equals
happiness things getting things is not
gonna make you happy that's good news in
a tough economy it's a good reminder you
know doesn't matter what you get doesn't
matter whether it be money or
opportunity all those things might
excite you for the moment you know even
a relationship as magnificent it may be
might be exciting for a while but if you
don't keep growing that relationship
isn't gonna stay exciting so the secret
to real happiness is progress progress
equals happiness and if we can make
progress on a regular basis we feel
alive and that's why at the beginning
here we get this thing like okay I could
have this fresh start I could really do
what my soul desires I could expand I
could grow I can improve I could change
or maybe better than change I could
progress see think about that progress
is an aliveness to it doesn't it
you have to work at changing people say
all the time that allow I'm working on
changing don't worry about it you have
to work on changing changes automatic
your body's gonna change whether you
want it or not as the years go by then
I'm gonna how hard you work there's
gonna be some changes going on there if
the economy is gonna change the matter
what you want it to do the weather is
gonna change relationships are gonna
change everything in life is always
changing we'll have to work on change
change is automatic but progress is not
so if you want to make real progress
then you really got to look at your life
in a different way you gotta say I gotta
take control of this process and not
just hope that's gonna work out like
people do who make a resolution rule
number four love your customers treat
people at the end of the relationship
like it's the beginning and it won't be
then and that's not just your intimate
relationship what if your customers what
if you fell in love with your customers
with your clients more than your product
more than your company if your entire
life was about meeting their needs if
you would do what for your customers
glad she would do what if you loved your
customers and clients you'd do anything
guess what they're gonna love you but
most people love their customers and
clients as long as they buy from them do
what they want respond to them and then
they don't they go that's the end you
want clients for life not just customers
fall in love with them it's a different
focus isn't it it's a different meaning
and that creates a different life
because you make decisions differently
from that place rule number five add
value does it take to create world-class
marketing what is the unique selling
proposition what is what we call
value-added marketing V I am today
most people are sick and tired of
advertising because where is it
everywhere in fact I got a question for
you
how many of you in this room do not even
see banner ads anymore literally it's
there but you don't perceive it like
there's like your brain literally washes
it out raise your hand if that's true
keep your hands nice and
I and look around the room right now and
you'll see 98% of the people wash it out
so don't buy them unless you're gonna
create something really unique it's a
total waste of your money and your time
in the world rent today today what
creates marketing is when you don't just
market but you add value to people you
do something you teach them you give
them an insight you give something
valuable that cost them nothing and then
they look to you as an expert they look
to you as a person that adds value they
want they want you to supply them more
information more experience more
products more services rule number six
have an exit strategy if you let made
this whole business about meeting your
needs you can run a successful business
but it'll be a job because you'll never
be able to sell it because it was just
meeting your needs it's not a system it
demands your attention or your
connection it's giving what you want but
ultimately it's not going to give
somebody else what they want so you
can't sell it if you can't sell your
business if you don't have an exit
strategy you have a job I don't care how
successful the businesses that doesn't
mean you have to sell the business but
one of the most important decisions you
make in business is ultimately if I was
gonna sell this my chose two I have to
know who when I sell this to you so that
I have long term value not just didn't
even come along the way I have this
critical mass here I get a multiple of
my business and most people don't have a
clear exit strategy they think I'll come
up with that someday you're gonna start
with that end in mind that's got to be
part of your focus if you're gonna be
successful in your business I can
remember gentlemen is built CAA in
Hollywood is largest most successful
agency right Michael Ovitz remember that
name he put together Nike and coca-cola
and these billion-dollar deals and
eventually Mike Ovitz want to go sell
that business he'd never thought through
an exit strategy they got almost nothing
for it cuz the laws prevented him from
selling it to a studio he oughta sell to
some his employees for pennies on its
real value there Mike found a way to
make money later on another place off of
Disney but the bottom line is the guy
didn't have an exit strategy there was
brilliant made lots of money in the end
didn't get the value rule number seven
be resourceful whenever people fail to
achieve their goals ninety-nine point
from the time you ask him why they'll
tell you it's because of a lack of
resources that's what all these things
are I didn't have the support right I
didn't have the money we didn't have the
time we didn't have this we know that
there's a resource that people believe
is missing and that resource belief
structure then keeps people from ever
being able to really lead because what
leaders do is they find a way to
maximize whatever resources they have
has little as they may be and they don't
believe in limited resources I'll give
an example take a business example to
start with in 1974 I gave me him Sam
Walton had built his little company on a
cable that idea he started with $20,000
and I think 1962 if I remember right but
by 1974 within 12 years he had 78 stores
and you know I did it in the middle of
the night he drive across the border and
he'd go and study other people's pours
he'd buy everything the cheapest he
could in the middle tonight he'd go to
people's stores whatever was working he
figured out success leaves Clues he came
back and did in his store whatever was
working in any store in any competitor
anywhere he could do it he did it so he
forgot how to maximize the little
resources he had his twenty thousand
build 78 stores and if you read any of
the people following him the company's
gone public in that year they were all
saying this is it
he's maximized his resources I mean I
only have so much money there's only so
many cities that are gonna appeal to
this discounting mentality right this is
it this is all he can do and the word of
Wall Street was self now what's
interesting is at that time you look at
Sears and Kmart and they were gargantuan
companies weren't that 20 30 40 50 times
100 times his size or more probably and
at that time they were the leaders and
they knew what's gonna happen but two
things change yes or no did he suddenly
get mass amounts of capital no here's
what they didn't understand Sam Walton
now or the Walton organization Walmart
is the most successful retailing
operation on earth and we talk about
Bill Gates being the richest man in the
world that's only true because Sam's
fortune has divided up amongst a bunch
of different family members you put them
together they dwarf Bill Gates Sam
Walton did this how did he do it what
people underestimate
is that this guy could go to 4,400
stores do 250 billion wears Kmart today
and they've been shrinking all them in
shrinking and he's the dominant force on
earth here's the rethink he understood
resources are interesting but the
ultimate resources are the feelings of
emotion that make you resourceful think
of it this way resourcefulness is the
ultimate resource what do I mean what
are the emotions that make all this
possible what's the fuel that takes an
idea from being in your head well you
intellectually know what to do how many
got an idea for example was a great idea
you're excited about it and then you
didn't do anything one day there you saw
it on the Shelf you saw it somewhere so
let's stole your idea how many had this
happen say I do understand you and that
person was not that they have more
resources they were more resourceful
rule number eight pay attention to the
little things success and failure are
not giant events they don't just show up
you don't just suddenly become
successful or suddenly have this
cataclysmic event that makes you fail
may look that way but fail your
condiments of all the little things its
failure to make the call its failure to
check the books its failure to say I'm
sorry its failure to push yourself to do
things physically that you don't want to
do and all those little failures day
after day come together until one day
some Cataclysm if it happens you blame
Matt they have event happen because you
missed all the little stuff do you agree
with me and success by the way is not
some overnight event it's all these
little things success is having a vision
and success is making a compelling
success is really seeing and feeling and
every day was strong enough for reasons
success he is feeling the sense that I'm
here to grow and I'm here to give
something to the world more than just
myself all the little stuff that's where
success comes from in business it comes
from delivering more than anybody could
imagine all those little things add up
people go wow that's who I want to do
business with it's true in any area of
your life rule number nine look for
leverage leverage is critical you know I
get so much done
cuz I don't just get it done I know the
outcome I know the purpose and I look
for leverage
leverage is different than delegation
what's problem with delegation
delegation is you have all that needs to
be done so you give it to someone else
and you tell them it needs to be done
and they don't do it you're pissed off
leverage says I can move the biggest
Boulder in the world with a little bit
of effort if I get something I can do it
with but I'm still part of it
so leverage is if I'm gonna leverage
something your thumb I'm gonna make sure
Tom understands the what the outcome I
want to show Tom understands the the
purpose the why and the action but I
might say - Tom if you get this done
without this action or better actually
go for a baby and I want to talk to you
on this date and we got a promise and
we're gonna check in before it's needed
so there's no surprises if you have any
problems Tom come back to me cuz we're
partners on this now I call leverage and
you know what I do when I have no time
there is time I just got to leverage it
now saying yeah I know what a leverage
it to you know Shane over here right I
thought all stuff he wants to do we
can't leverage it but Shane's answer was
hire somebody then he thinks about
what's gonna take and goes 125 thousand
dollars I can't do that now he's getting
caught up in one way to get the outcome
leverage he goes to his listing goes
what if I got somebody to 20% of this
stuff I got I could spend 20 grand to
get that much freedom I could pay for it
times 10 hmm and if I'm really
productive my productivity should
enhance the world not only my clients
and customers but it should provide jobs
for other people and if there's anything
you hate to do it's because you're
either ineffective at it or you don't
think it's very important but it is
urgent so you to hire somebody for those
things and ideally somebody who loves
that job you're never gonna grow when
your time is eaten up for activities
that aren't that important activity
without high levels of purpose is the
drain of your fortune do it now if you
can't get it all now to a part of it now
leverage is power leverages ultimate our
real number 10 change your mindset
here's what I've created for my life and
anyone I know succeeded I'm a 17 year
old kid from Azusa California with no
real education other than self education
with no background with parents that did
their best all of them
with no money but I did one thing I love
people and I had an enormous demand I
made upon myself and I sculpted my mind
and my emotions to get me to do whatever
it would take to achieve and to
contribute but to do that I did it by
using my body and changing my focus I
did it by putting myself in a peak
physiology and using what I call
incantations can you train yourself to
believe something yes or no
absolutely how many have ever made the
fatal mistake of going to Disneyland or
Disney World and while you're there made
the fatal mistake of going to a ride
called it's a small world after all what
happens for about a week after you're
out of that damn place you're still
singing this thing in your head and 24
languages right let me tell you
something how many of you have things
when you want to achieve them and this
part of your voice goes on it's not
gonna happen or forget it I'm gonna go
to voices sometimes interrupts that good
pattern say what you want to do is train
a new one so starting when I was 17 I
started doing incantations not
affirmations affirmation you go home at
the Olympia mantheon happy I'm happy
what's the problem you haven't changed
your what your what physiology if you
don't change your physiology you won't
get anything
so in incantations you only you speak it
but you embody what you're saying with
all the intensity you can and you do it
with enough repetitions that it sticks
in your head like it's a small world now
the conversation your head is always the
same and it gives you what you want so
use your body and your voice so 17 years
ago I started doing things I was working
for Jim Rohn this speaker when I was 17
years old I had long hair minestrone
soup acne on my face and I was trying to
call on Bear Stearns type of people and
convince them why they should go to this
man seminar be more successful
I was driving 1968 Volkswagen that I had
earned at $40 a week as a janitor the
only way I did it was parked far from
the building and then go in and I love
people I believe but I put myself in
state and I was able to influence people
that were far more successful I was at
the time I will do something that I
still do backstage and have done for 23
years because I don't hope I'm gonna be
good stay I demand it so I do an
incantation using my whole body that's a
command my subconscious mind to direct
me and helping as many people's possible
life today to better their lives they
gave me the strength the emotion the
persuasion the humor the brotherly
whatever it takes
you surely feel and get these people to
change their lives now I would do that
literally driving in my Volkswagen to a
meeting in LA on the freeway for 40
minutes people look at my I'm screaming
to pop my lungs they're going I know
he's a serial killer I know he is but by
the time I entered that room when two
people meet if there's a rapport the
person who's most certain will always
influence the other person and I was
probably certain and they were trying to
get grabbed up to certainty you agree
with this yes or no I do another one
because I was poor I changed my mindset
I kept doing things but I never got
beyond it
I'd say gods wealth is circulating in my
life as well flows to me and avalanches
of abundance all my needs desires and
goals are met instantaneously by
infinite intelligence for I'm one with
God and God's everything and I would
imagine the abundance of my life and I
would feel so grateful and a year later
I went for making thirty eight thousand
dollars a year to make a million dollars
a year and one year rule number 11 be
hungry if you ask what does it take to
succeed the one answer I give them as
hunger
that hunger is the greatest asset that
you'll see everybody from Richard
Branson to Google or an apple or
Facebook these little giant companies
you got to become a master of your
ability to turn on your determination or
your creativity or your hunger or your
passion or whatever it is it's gonna
take for you to get from where you are
to where you really want to be
intelligence is so valuable but there's
so many smart people I can't fight the
way out of a paper bag
hunger is that part of you that says I
will not stop I will not get up I will
not settle for less than I can be or do
or share or give rule number 12 raise
your standards a number one thing that's
gonna change your life
the only thing that will change your
life change your business change your
money change your relationship because
you must raise your standard now I know
that sounds boring stupid basic but it's
the truth
the only thing that changes our life
long-term is when we raise our standards
what does that mean that sounds so
boring and dumb it means that all of us
in life have things we want we don't get
what we want we get what we have to have
remember I said earlier we all get what
we tolerate in ourselves and other
people but when you're no longer willing
to tolerate something that's when your
life changes the difference in people is
their standards period the difference in
people is their standards period and
what I mean by standards everyone in the
world has a list of things they think
they should do I should lose weight I
should work out I should spend more time
with my kids I should work harder I
should make more calls I should I should
I should I should and then you know what
people don't do their sheds and they get
mad at themselves and they when I call
[ __ ] all over themselves they beat them
scope up about it
what changes people is when you should
becomes a must when suddenly the thing
you said should
and has to happen that's when human
beings change it's like if you want to
take the island and you're the head of
the army and you want to take the art
island the most powerful way to take the
island is burn the boats cuz if there's
no way to go back it's amazing what
happens when it's a must to do something
versus a [ __ ] that's what makes human
being succeed rule number 13 decide to
be happy so you really have to decide
the most important decision is do I want
to be happy will I commit to being happy
more important than happy sometimes
you'd be so happy to smile so much your
face hurts right you need variety am I
committed to living in a beautiful state
even when it doesn't go my way even when
it rains on my parade even when my
biggest fear shows up because I can't
control whether you're husband and wife
will live or die or get sick or leave
you or get a divorce I don't want any of
that to happen any human being I hate
suffering I do anything I can't help
people's not suffer and I can't control
that you can you can there are people
have lost their arms lost their sight
there have been people that have been
through the most horrific experiences
life and they found a way to still be
happy because they've made the decision
that life is too short to suffer I've
interviewed dozens and hundreds over the
years but dozens that like have impacted
my soul that made me realize and I can't
change this I've just gotten used to it
I bought into the theory that this this
survival software that's constantly
running and making you suffer that
that's normal
no that's what the mind will do and mind
has been around forever what I'm gonna
do is something different and the way I
get out of suffering I gave myself a 90
second rule it's really simple
I say look if I feel myself starting to
feel that stress feeling that pissed-off
nasur upsetness or concern or worry but
my kid whatever I realize that's not
gonna make it better life's too short to
suffer and then I just kind of breathe
slowly slow everything down can I just
watch the thought globe I know look at
that crazy [ __ ] nobody's that crazy
thought so every said I thought I'm
gonna kill that son of a [ __ ] right and
then you don't kill him cuz you don't
believe that thought it's the thoughts
that are stressful that you believe that
mess you up when you question them you
break the pattern and the morof dentist
like a muscle the more I've trained
myself to do it I can authentically tell
you now it takes all
wat for something to take more than 90
seconds for me now and the level of joy
surpasses all the money who could ever
have in a million years and then the
money it's easier to make money because
you're not attached you don't have the
fears you don't have the scarcity that
people have because you feel so rich
already right now
I always some people don't wait to be
rich what is that richness it's abundant
such joy it's happiness its contribution
it's getting out of yourself
because as long as we're thinking about
oh my god
I lost something or you did something
now I have less love less respect less
money if I think lost less or because
you did something or because I did
something I'm never gonna have what I
want in my life lost less than ever
those three thought patterns they're the
source of all suffering and they have to
go see it for what it really is
no it's BS and find something to
appreciate rule number 14 master one
thing most people who start business
very often will start two and three four
more and the reason they do it is does
the first one isn't succeeding or they
no longer laminations exactly right and
so what happens that person is they're
never going to be successful in most
case unless they get lucky you get more
people bounce across something that's
easier to do but most people are always
looking for that next level what my view
is is it's great to test all these
things but you got to find what is your
flagship but what is it that you're
gonna commit your soul to because if you
don't do that the inevitable channels
are gonna come up and you're gonna then
move on to something on your personal
level and so the other going to look at
is business is about constantly
exploding such massive value doing more
for others anybody else but it's also
simultaneously about your own psychology
it's your ability to go through
thresholds of control it's like I can
remember when I didn't have fifty
thousand dollars keep the doors open on
my company I had twelve employees and
eleven wanted to quit cuz they hated the
person running the show and fifty
thousand dollars to be like five hundred
million to me today and I figured out
how to get through that threshold and
once I did like all the problems are
related that were handled I know you've
done this as well and then I you know I
have a five million dollar
lawsuit was totally unfair unjust and I
finally had a just amount of time
entertaining I had a bite the bullet do
it five million was more than I've ever
met
let me have a partner who took a company
losing a million dollars a day and
turned into 1.5 billion and positive
EBIT uh I'm not mentioning names my and
he wanted me to join in a business with
some other partners not doing the
multi-level side did the business put in
ten million bucks we all put in ten
millions forty million to death but I
signed joint in several which I didn't
understand in those days what that meant
and two of my partners were supposedly
billionaires and they went broke we
bought some more companies I end up with
a hundred and twenty million dollars in
debt that I was on the hook for no one
else had any money and I didn't have to
do a seminar wanted to throw up there
was a new threshold of control so you
know when you ski or snowboard and you
think you're maybe you're just new at it
and you think you're going down a blue
or green it turns out to be a double
block yeah and so you have two choices
one is you start to go down and you
freak out you're gonna die you slam on
the ground to try to hang on for dear
life or the other is baby you focus on
where you want to go in Coweta weight
curve you find a way to cut and once you
do it a couple of times you know you
have no more fear of that element not my
biggest one out of that that led me to a
billion I have thirty one companies now
to give you an idea seven different
industries its diverse is like you know
stem cells to virtual reality with
exclusive to the NBA now virtually how
to give an example if we do I got 1200
poised were on three continents and we
got five billion dollars in sales but I
did that my first date on one friggin so
masterful at it
rule number fifteen don't give up there
is another level the only reason you
keep saying there isn't as you feel so
exhausted about where you are but life
the universe or God is just testing you
because there is another level if this
is good
giant jump to excellence Giants start a
good poor to good to excellence there's
a level where all your dreams are
realized there's a level that you've
always dreamed that it is real it has
not gone away but it takes that extra
burst when you think there's nothing
left there's no way you've tried
everything ten million times
and you keep going it's almost like God
is saying if you keep hitting this wall
enough times I will see that you will
not stop that you were filled with that
level of determination faith and courage
and then the door opens and you get to
that next level but most people don't
know is the next level is just two
millimeters above and it's called
outstanding ladies and gentlemen
outstanding what's it called what's it
called what's it called outstanding
magnificent unstoppable extraordinary
not excellent it's a different level
it's a level where you are not one of
the best you are the best you know
what's amazing you only have to be two
millions more than everybody else and
you get everything you get the joy the
last day the father the family the
passion the economics the freedom the
spirit it's all there what Jerry Maguire
called the Quan baby all of it and it's
just two million years above and most
excellent people give up because they're
exhausted and there's some people go the
harder I hit it the more I hit it sooner
or later it's going down I'm not
stopping and when you do that enough it
pops open rule number 16 live in the
state of gratitude if you're obsessed
you know what you want you take a
massive action maybe you modeled
somebody figure out the right action so
you get there quicker and you're
executing you still need a little grace
some people call it luck you could call
God but I really believe that there's
the part we do and then there's the part
that comes to us but I do know grace
shows up a lot more when you do the
first two steps on your own and grace
shows up a lot more when you acknowledge
grace in your life when you acknowledge
that I was born in a world where I
didn't have to build this internet that
I can pull out of my pocket the answer
anything on earth I'm driving on streets
I didn't pave I'm reading books I didn't
have to write that's the gift of our
lives and I think when we experience
that grace we don't just experienced
more achievement but we start to
experience more fulfillment and grace
not only affects your ability to get
there but it affects what you do and how
you lean you live once you are there it
really determines the quality of your
life because unless you live in a state
of gratitude yeah I did an interview
with Sir John Templeton who as you know
is one of the first billionaire
investors and just a brilliant man he
came from nothing and he don't eat any
was seven and fifteen they still do it
the Templeton fund I think it's seven
and fifty million dollars a year it's
bigger than a Nobel fund that he donates
and one day asked them I said what is
the secret to wealth and he looked to me
pause this big smile and his eyes got
really bright like they always did and
he said Tony it's what you teach I said
well I teach a lot of things you know
it's thing he said gratitude he said
because you night oneno billionaires
that are miserable and it's because
they're not grateful for what they have
and we both know people have no money
seemingly but they're so grateful for
their health for their husband for their
life for their children they're so
grateful to God they're so grateful for
their life that they're rich you know so
I think I think it starts with that
gratitude it starts with that connection
to grace is simplistic as that sounds
and so it's not enough just to have your
financial plan you have all the money
and be miserable
what's all the money and be really rich
emotionally psychologically it's largely
rule number seventeen learn from failure
failure is part of life I mean the
difference for me though is I'm like a
failure as a stepping stone to success
it's a speed bump I know I'm gonna fail
but it's not failure if you learn
something and so gosh I've made so many
mistakes I've screwed so many things up
but every time I do it just becomes it
becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what I've done I think I
have the ability influence people
because I talk about my failures I talk
about all the things that messed me up
but I show people that didn't want to
stop me and you only to stop you and I
think I think that's really the secret
matter and if everything you touch was
successful first I got to relate to
people as much and also it's B total
bullsh and everyone no it's both and
also you'd be bored silly I mean think
about it if you just said I want this
and happen I want this to happen you
know people don't value it they don't
fight for you know it's like you see
kids sometimes in it you know your
parents will say you're not gonna value
this if you don't work for it and your
kid going oh well you'll just give it to
me yeah but it's true you know about
things we've worked the hardest for we
value the most so I think you know the
purpose of the goal is not getting it
anyway the purpose of goal you know is
what who you become
will you becomes gonna make you happier
it's gonna make you sad so I'm not
looking for an effortless approach
there's no such thing rule number 18
stay disciplined so Tony one of the
critics actually that I once met said
yeah Tony's techniques they were great
for about a year and a half and then
they wore off what do you say to that
it's a real simple if you don't work out
you don't get a you don't get a muscle
right so I always tell people this is
there's a daily practice like priming if
you don't do that if you get up and you
just have no discipline whatsoever you
get no value of anything your diets
don't work when you don't do them
exercise doesn't work when you don't do
them but most people have some
experiences that they want to shift and
once you shift those things your whole
life changes but life is constant growth
my life isn't here because I went to one
seminar one time and now my life is fit
for life I I workout I train my mind and
train my body it becomes a lifestyle
it's not just like you're depending upon
somebody else I'm gonna here to become
somebody's guru I'm not here to give
them a gift I'm here them to open up
their own gifts and that's really what
my work has been rule number 19 use fear
the only way to deal with fear that I
found in my life is a couple of ways one
of those ways is to turn it on itself
and ask yourself what am I afraid of I'm
free of that I got to be more afraid of
what I'm gonna miss out on missing out
on my mission this thing out who I'm
supposed to be missing in other words if
you know I did get rid of fear than use
fair use fear or it uses you it's that
simple
so you gotta say okay what's the price
if I just stay doing this what's the
price what I need to really even get
scared if I learn all this I don't
follow through that's something to be
scared about
and then that fear will get you over
your fear it'll push you through turn
fear in itself second way you can do it
is use what you've probably heard me say
because I've used it so much seventeen
is my little rocking chair test right
I'm gonna I'm gonna sit myself in my
rocking chair I'm I'm 85 years old and
looking back on my life and I say I
didn't do this or I did rule number 20
keep the momentum going if you find your
passion you're gonna have this
tremendous energy a sustainable energy
but momentum requires you always do the
next thing that keep the momentum going
and the reason you get yourself in a
passionate place
and so that you changed your life and
the only thing that changes your life is
making a decision so while you're in
this passionate state that's where you
make decisions you don't make decisions
when you're like oh I don't know what do
you think all right let's decide if you
make a decision in a state without
momentum if you make a decision from a
place where there's no passion you are
not gonna get momentum it'll kill
momentum it's decide commit and resolve
some of you in the past you've gotten
momentum you've gotten passionate you've
even made a decision but a decision is
the first step decision is like a war I
gotta do this or that all right I'm
gonna make myself do this but commitment
is when you nail after you've decided
you commit to do this for the long term
whether it's hard or easy doesn't matter
you're doing this it takes it from this
moment and it carries it into the future
even when things are difficult and the
third state is resolved resolved means
it's done it's like it doesn't even if
you took actually it's done inside you
so it's done out there there's no
question whatsoever then once you decide
the only way the commitment and the
energy and the momentum continues is if
you take immediate massive what my
friends massive life write down in your
notes massive action is the cure-all
massive action is the cure-all if you're
having a difficult time with something
your relationship isn't where you want
it to be your finances are not where you
want to be your body's not where you
want to be your business is not where it
want to be you need take massive action
and if that doesn't work try something
else so that's his work try something
else keep going with massive action and
you will find the way because it will
give you momentum
rule number 21 find fulfillment
fulfillment is an art what's going to
fulfill you is differently at first next
you not gonna learn that from
else you got to find it because success
without fulfillment is the ultimate
failure and I get those phone calls all
the time for the multi billionaire
entrepreneur or politician or business
person or a person just won their
Academy Award and they're depressed and
they can't tell anybody because they got
all their goals but they're not
fulfilled because they really don't have
that sense of meaning in their life they
went for something and they got it they
achieved and if you doubt this what I'm
saying is relevant to you or us or
anyone just think about about a year and
what a month ago we lost what I consider
be a national treasure robbing wipes how
many of you loved robbing wipes look
around they don't keep the hands of look
and most of you didn't know him almost
ever and then where you go in the world
people love Robin Williams by the way
was he great at achievement oh my god
that guy he said he want to make become
a great comedian he did that I want to
make the world laugh he did I want to
make my own TV show he did I wanted the
number one TV show he did it I want to
make movies he did I want an Academy
Award for not being funny not his skill
set drama and he did it I want a
beautiful family he did it and then he
hung himself make everybody happy but
yourself
not a good plan so if I had a gift to
give you it would be maybe make a
different decision and a decision is
that no matter what happens in your life
you're gonna live in a beautiful state a
beautiful state and that could be happy
that could be grateful that could be
being generous those are all beautiful
states aren't they it could be curious
it could be fun it could be playful
you're not limited to one state but it's
different than suffering and most people
suffering and all suffering I've ever
seen I traveled 100 countries I've dealt
with presence of countries and you know
presidents of businesses CEOs I've dealt
with people in prison I thought with you
name it average people suffering always
comes because you're obsessed about
something related to you you can only be
depressed if you're focusing on yourself
so now I'm depressed cuz my kids and and
they're not doing well no you're
depressed cuz you feel you've failed
your kids it's about you it's about how
you think you what you should have done
shouldn't have done or what someone did
to you or didn't do to you in the past
through the future which don't even
exist so I have a simple goal my goal is
help people make a decision that says I
don't know what's gonna happen you might
get a divorce even though you don't
think so you might find a family of your
family with cancer you might have your
house get burned down or have a tornado
go by and if you live in the same place
that happens every two years and you
move back we should talk but some people
seem to do that for some reason you
can't control those things I can't
control those things I don't want those
to happen to you or anybody I love or
anybody who's even a stranger to me but
they're going to happen true not
positive thinking both just the truth so
if that's gonna happen I say make a
decision now that says I'm gonna live in
a beautiful state and I'm gonna find
beauty and whatever Life brings me cuz
life is too short not to rule number 22
feed your mind with greatness
so what do you think was the first real
breakthrough that you had as a team that
started you on your path and how did you
get there Tasha so many one of the first
ones I think was probably just anchoring
in when my mom and my dad had courted
fathers my mom was a powerful woman so
she kicked my fourth father out whose
name I carry and he adopted me and when
he went out she decided was in his side
so she kicked me out too by chasing out
with a knife and I wasn't worried she's
gonna stab me or anything but I decided
this is freedom I've gotta find a way to
make my life work but I had no money out
of 1960 Volkswagen I worked 40 dollars a
week as a janitor to buy and pay for and
so I had no car and no money I don't
know anything
I went slept in a person's laundry room
and then I decided I've gotta figure out
what to do with I need to feed my money
because I was so depressed I was so
overwhelmed I'm missing my brother and
sister and feeling just completely out
of sorts so I I got on the bus and I
traveled 14 miles a member because I
didn't running at one time and I was in
this book store and I bought this book
called the magic of believing my quad
head crystals the first real book other
than maybe thinking go rich or Emerson's
essays and I started on this journey of
saying every single day I'm gonna feed
my mind I'm not going to hope good
thoughts show up I'm gonna read
biographies I'm gonna I'm gonna find out
what makes people tick
understand what makes me tick and I
wanted to read a book a day but I didn't
do that click to the speed reading class
and I read some of our books over seven
years and they're all personal
development human development psychology
physiology and then what I try to do is
take anything that I learned and apply
it and then when I applied it you know I
was 5-1 in my sophomore in high school
I'm six seven now I thought people
differences personal growth but
sincerely I I became mister solution
because I wanted to help everybody so I
was this little fat guy and I couldn't
lose weight and I lost weight all my
buddies are like how'd you do that I
said well here's what I did they lost
weight y'all got girls and as a young
kid given that led to where you know if
you have problem I was mister solution
specially if your girl has so the
breakthrough was really understanding
the power of compressing decades in the
days and if someone has spent decades of
their life and they compress it into a
book and you can read it in an hour or a
few days you have such an advantage
because when you learn by your own
experience it's painful and it's slow
when you learn by other people's
experience everybody knows in the
financial world other people's money is
leveraged right well other people's
experience is more powerful in other
people's money because you can have the
money and lose it but if you get the
experience you can change it all so I
think that was the beginning for me and
it set me on a wife long path of hire
and I never lost my hunger rule number
23 own your business the middle of my do
is I'd want to know more about my
clients than anybody that may know about
themselves I know a man that from
Australia decided he's a dentist and he
decided he was tired of people not
showing up he was tired of trying to
bill and not getting paid you know
properly there's insurance and he was
taught all these things one day he just
decided to sit down with everyone was
patients 101 and he said I'm changing my
practice I'm gonna practice where I'm
gonna take a lot less clients and let go
probably have two clients laughs right
now I only want to do business with
people who I personally like who when
they come in I want to sit down have a
cup of tea with them both understand
what's going on in their life what their
goals are and I want to make sure that
everything in my psyche is taken care of
them and helping them augment the way
they look the way they
feel and their vitality and the health
of their system and he sat down and said
so to do that I want you to know I have
some simple thanks I'm promising I'll
give you the best dental care of your
entire life I'm promising that if you
come in your appointment you will not be
delayed more maximum of five minutes
ever
I'm anyway than all these things I get
the best care this this the most most
attention he goes but this is what I'm
gonna require for patients that work
with me our further about someone else
that this is uncomfortable he said I
require that if they cancel they're
gonna have to pay for it I require they
show up on time because I'm gonna
respect them they respond me I'm going
to also require that in the next six
months that if I do the quality work
that I promised they'll give me two
referrals to other quality people I'd
probably want to take care of as well
and he said I'm shutting down any other
form of my business and I'm gonna spend
more quality time with you and I want
the referrals because I don't spend time
marketing and selling I'm spent I'm
putting my attention and making your
life better
he quadrupled his income and cut the
time he spent doing dental work by more
than 60 percent just because he became
an owner who owned his business instead
of running around trying to please
everybody and being frustrated people
are canceling and so forth most of us
just don't own ourselves enough right
rule number 24 change your story when
something is considered quote/unquote
impossible how do you reframe it so it
becomes possible in your mind and how
much of that is mindset well I think
impossible is not a fact it's an opinion
when someone tells me it's impossible
I always just look at anybody around me
knows that they can't do this that's
part of it but if they didn't know me
it's your opinion then I'll say no
science shows and I say yeah and how
many times the science shows something's
impossible now science shows it's
possible things are impossible till
somebody does it and so I find that you
know most of your business people you
look at businesses and what does it take
to make a business grow it's not
impossible like a business grow up has
been shrinking for a long time or it's
been stuck the real problem is always
the chokehold as always the psychology
and the skills of the leader always an
80% of that as psychology and 20% is the
mechanics like if you don't know how to
read your financials and you're trying
to fly the plane of your your company I
mean come on you know if all you do is
go down
you look at profit loss and you see what
it is and you have a beer either way you
either celebrated at the brass you know
something you know you're gonna be in
trouble right but if you have the
skillsets that's one thing but you can
get any skill set if you have the
psychology and anytime a business is not
growing it is not because it's
impossible it's because they aren't
innovating and they're not innovating
because they're believing it's
impossible I mean if we all know what
does it take to transform obviously uh
people it takes three things to create a
breakthrough and anything and your
personal life in your business anywhere
you need a strategy but that's not the
first place you should look in it the
first place all of us look me too
it's our adherent thing you want to lose
weight well how do I do it I want to
grow my business how do I do it it's
it's instinctively been trained to think
that way but the problem is the how-to
is usually not that complex gonna come
on
70% of America is what 75% of America
now is overweight is that because it's
so complex that have you fit and strong
right you know only the 1% know the
answer is they hide it from you you have
to work your ass off to not hear what it
takes right and so so you know I
remember I went to this I went to a TED
med Center and I watched about 12
doctors won't have to get up and do
these stories about if we could just get
patients to take their medications and
try to figure out the whole thing and I
was just looking and going you're all
talking about strategy you've forgotten
psychology because strategy's wonderful
I'm a strategist but my whole life
figuring out strategies is we both know
a strategy could save you a decade right
and business strategy could save you you
know it could make the difference T in
success and failure but most people have
strategies available or they could get
them or you could create them but the
problem is you got a story and your
story is why it isn't working and the
story is I've tried what but everything
if you tried everything you'd be fit
right you tried everything you'd be
profitable if you tried everything you'd
be there but people said you know I'm
big-boned that's what I used to say I'm
still big-boned but I'm 38 pounds
lighter than I was 25 years ago and I've
never gained it back right a borrow his
big bone that was my story all the good
ones are gone that's why I'm not in a
relationship or their gain I'm not
in game they are whatever the story is
there's always a story and what I tell
people's you know if you can just
divorce the story of your limitation and
marry the truth of your unlimited
capacity then the whole game changes
room at 25 be obsessed with adding value
when you went off on your own you know
that's kind of the point I think people
you know most businesses fail at the
beginning in the first few years so
there you are on your own what do you
think were the keys to success those
first few years by yourself
obsession without any more value than
anybody else ever dreamed of I mean my
entire life from the very beginning days
was how do I do more for others than
anyone else on earth how do I give them
experiences that are lasting how do I
create change what change was impossible
I'm going to take somebody from the
therapy for seven years in an hour
produced that result and the way I did
that was by challenging traditional
psychologists and psychiatrists and
getting on national radio and saying
giving you were stationed on handle in
an hour which was pretty abrasive you
know as a young kid you can get by with
that stuff but the best part was I
backed it up and so one of the first
interventions I did was in Vancouver
British Columbia Canada on the radio and
this psychiatrist got on the phone and
just on the radio why I'm just
passionate you are a liar you're a
charlatan people like you should not be
loud on the radio and I said sir I said
I said are you you know scientists used
to the course of a physician I said well
scientists would never make an
assumption I said you've never met me
right now you've never met my clients
know you call me a liar on national
radio I said she must be stating your
hypothesis your hypothesis is that I'm
gonna Charlotte and if you're staying
hypothesis and you're truly a scientist
you gotta be willing to test it am i
right yeah yeah it's a great I'm doing a
free guest event the Holiday Inn
tomorrow night anyone hearing my voice
can come I went into a series of
demonstrations and I'm gonna take one of
your clients and turn around I said
share with me somebody that you've never
been able to change I said I'm sure you
got plenty of those you want to play
hardball
you're one of patients that aren't ready
to change and I said I haven't found any
course I've done three therapies
so hopefully a long story short he told
me this one we've been working on for
seven years
it's what a snake phobia a phobia is not
just a fear it's a bunny control
response to fear so like she dreamed the
snake would bite her on the face and
then the adrenaline shoot through her
body and wake her up
and there's a nap in four to seven times
a night seven years so you know he was
put in the corner and so he brought her
down and it took me about 15 minutes at
the end of it
I tested first and she's training and
shaking and then I wrapped the snake
around her and that changed my entire
career because in that moment everything
there was no question everybody honey
thunder this woman is transformed I said
you've been treated though that's like
nitrogen how many years yeah then I took
on sports stars so that I could turn
around you know I did some work with
Mother Teresa
Nelson Mandela Bill Clinton and as the
years went by it just built it dr. Joe
rule number 26 focus everyone in this
room knows how to create you're not a
manager of your life you're a creator of
your life or you wouldn't be in this
room how do you create your life you get
hungry for something don't you who has
done something your life that once
seemed difficult or impossible and now
it's part of your life who's got
something in your life in this area say
I how did you do it you created it three
ways number one you decided there's
something you wanted so bad that you
unleashed all your desire you became
obsessed with it if it was a business or
a car or a relationship or a
transformation in your body if there's
something you want sin vision and now
it's real it's because you didn't just
envision it you brought so much emotion
to it then now it's in your life it was
once a dream it was once a goal and now
it's in your life how many have
something like that in your life now say
I you may take it for granted now
hopefully not but it was once just a
vision may have seemed impossible at one
time so how did you do it you started
with a concrete vision of what you
wanted and you focused on it
continuously didn't you wherever focus
goes energy flows you envision something
you got clear about it and then you
started thinking about all the
why you wanted it you got excited about
it so this is what's next for me now I
want this you may have dreamed about a
thought about and talked about it but
when you focus on something continuously
something magical happens you get
insights don't you you overhear a
conversation hear something you wouldn't
have heard if you didn't have that
outcome or goal that you wanted so badly
who's ever come up with something
obsessed about it didn't even know how
to do it and it just happened and it
came together who's that that experience
say I so why don't we happened that
power now for your business in life rule
number 27 diversify the goal if you own
a business and I resume a lot of your
viewers are business owners or for
getting started in business no matter
how good you are in business think about
this the one universal rule that idiots
in finance know is diversification if
the only free lunch you've got a
diversify because if you put all your
eggs in one basket no matter how good
the basket is one day that real estate
market that stock market that bond
market that collectibles mark whatever
you invest in raid Elliott's showed me
statistically it'll drop 50 to 70
percent on a day now if you're later in
life and that happens it's over free of
that so you have to diversify and yet
most people may know real estate so they
do it or they know stocks they do it or
they grip the hand their parents
flipping things and it's the wrong thing
to do so you've got to diversify in
order for you to be able to truly
succeed and that's why when you want a
business yeah if you put all your money
in your business which is what most of
us do naturally yeah you put all your
eggs in one basket there's things that
can happen I mean you know you're let's
say you spend 20 years and you figured
out how to put together the ultimate map
you know and you remember Garmin came
out with this thing called the TomTom
and over your number used to get on your
I will enough to remember that before
anything yeah I just put on your badge -
yeah cost a hundred bucks it was a
breakthrough they're making like I'm
design or something or yeah yeah
six months later went out the iPhone
came out we have some apps these little
bastards as soon as my French came out
with it put Google Maps with their own
map on here and tell us how much zero
what was I gonna do to your business
once
take your product reserved it gives away
for free so I always tell people
competition happens technology happens
what you must do is have a second
business though with no moving parts no
people no time maybe it takes you 2 to 3
days a year for 2 or 3 hours after
you've read the book you put it in place
and you measure it two three times a
year that's it yeah go on with your life
now there's our trouble in your business
you're financially set I in my life have
thirty-one companies now we have you
know what do we have 1200 employees 7
different industries we do five billion
in sales I mean that used to be you know
me and my seminar business it's grown
geometrically but with all those moving
parts the only way I've been able to
succeed is because I've taken everyone
those businesses that I've diversified
my assets so that when things were in
trouble I still have enough economics
figure myself and keep the business
going so everybody needs to create a
money machine that works while you sleep
that doesn't have moving parts and
that's what this is really about
rule number 28 live your mission so what
are the trade-offs that you would
consider like you know we work our asses
off we do a lot of stuff but this is
what we had to sacrifice in order to do
it if you think it that way I think if
you think of it as a sacrifice
then you're gonna build frustration or
resentment
I really don't if you think it's that
question shouldn't do it I think the
challenge is that most people have this
illusion about life work balance and
that's you know if you're gonna
accomplish it it's what people are
laughing is you know it's [ __ ] right
what's true is life work integration so
I was just in twenty one country or
seven countries twenty-one days but
who's with me as my family who's with me
as my friends and I've done well enough
to have a plane and that brooms and all
that kind of cool stuff makes it but
when I didn't we still we pumped it
together and beginning days it was coach
and dragging ourselves around but I
thought it was great for my kids to have
schooling but I thought an education was
more valuable and traveling the earth
was a part of that but you know we're in
the middle of this crazy schedule but
we're it's not work it's a mission when
it's work it's that I was asked people I
said how would you describe what you do
and people I say because at work it's a
career as it mission and most people of
course say it's work and that's exactly
what is this heavy if it's you know if
it's your career it gives you some more
but your mission it doesn't wear you out
brings energy to you it's fulfilling and
if you can tie your mission in with the
people that you love it's pretty cool
you know there's some people let's
get'em they're my friends I see Dean
here in front row here and it's like
we're all on this mission and we find
time to connect and be with each other
and have a blast with each other but
we're sharing about things that matter
I'm not a person to go to a party and
like you know go on the corner and
chitchat it's like you want to talk
about something deep let's rock you
don't let me go home and be with my
family you know let me go do something
fun with it some of that nature if you
can combine your mission with your
family combine your mission with some of
your friends then you're gonna
accomplish a million times more but if
you think it's a sacrifice don't do it
because then all you're doing is you're
gonna have resentment later on or
frustration later on and and then you
really aren't contributing because it's
you're you're trading off you're not
giving rule number 29 believe most
people have a belief about what their
real potential isn't matter what you
tell them and that affects so much
action they take and of course that
affects the result and then ironically
that result reinforces their belief and
then that belief effects it so I'll give
an example let's say a person has
unlimited potential we all agree but
they take little action little results
why because they have to start with a
problem with their belief they don't
believe it's really gonna happen for me
maybe for Frank Kern's cuz it got the
cool hair and stuff or maybe it's for
you because you're so driven but it's
not me maybe Tony Robbins cuz she's a
freak out these big teeth whatever their
thought process is right they got this
thing right but what happens is if you
believe that there's very little
potential how much action you're gonna
take and when you take a little
potential with a little action what kind
of results you get lousy little results
when you have little results what does
that do to your belief you go see I told
you this was a waste of time soldier
this wouldn't work and then what happens
you tap even less potential to take even
less actually even the worst results and
your belief gets even weaker and this
sucker feeds on itself until you are in
a downward spiral poisonous it's
poisonous and it's self-fulfilling now
what if something could happen that
could come along and fill you with a
sense of absolute certainty not like I
believe but mean well you know and you
guys this case mine as well we knew
because we had to because we burned the
boats
no other option we had to find the way
we that we weren't gonna live that way
we all did it in different ways and for
different reasons but in that sense that
was it if you get yourself in a state of
certainty that this is gonna work I'm
gonna find the way and if this is work I
will make the way then you tap a lot
more potential and when you're certain
your potential you take massive action
when you take massive action you really
believe in something you get great
results when you get great results your
brain goes see I told you I was a stud I
told you this thing would worked out now
even stronger you have more potential
take greater action be results that's
how you went from 300 bucks in a week to
twenty five hundred and five days to a
hundred thousand and a month to a
million bucks in a day same thing with
you and we get momentum so where the
rich get richer the poor get poorer now
some people go out they go well I'm
gonna take a bunch of action all right
I'm gonna open this product gonna try it
they'll say to you I even did it but
it's like the salesman who goes and
knocks on the door he knocks on a
hundred doors and says verbally his face
says it because he doesn't believe it's
gonna work
so his voice his body the execution is
so weak maybe if he talks a hundred
people somebody's gonna buy on a pity
I'm gonna win his kids to starve right
but he's not gonna get the result so the
core difference in people is how do you
produce certainty when the world isn't
giving it to you you go out and try and
you try in your case you're a hundred
thousand a debt nothing's working how do
you keep yourself going the way you did
it the way I did it the way you're doing
it we may not done it consciously is we
didn't change our potential that was
there and it wasn't even taking more
action taking more action with beliefs
not gonna works not gonna change
anything we got results in our head that
made us feel certain as if it had
already happened real number 30 let go
put your hands on your heart if you
would okay my hands on my heart feel
your heart close your eyes are really
breathing hard those at home could do
the same so they can test this out and
those are home think of something that's
really bothering you I deal with is 7 or
above and you really want to resolve it
and yeah it could be a relationship
situation of business situation kids
whatever breathe in your heart and
actually physically feel your heart feel
it filling with blood and oxygen feel
the beauty of your heart ah yes
I love getting a heart exam because you
get to hear that it's the strength of
your heart yeah feel the beauty the
strength and through what you're
grateful your heart is guided you to do
in this life so many beautiful things
especially you oh and there's your
breathing and feeling that I want you to
think of three things one at a time just
a couple minutes we'll do a short
version here I know you have a couple
minutes but things you're really
grateful for but something that could be
little or big oh but if you step into
that moment you can feel it right now
like you're there yeah yeah breathe it
feel it enjoy it mmm show up with it and
then think of a second one
that you can feel really grateful for
and see it through your own eyes as if
you were there and really take it in
okay and then pick up a third one find
what I really really enjoy feel like it
was a blessing such a beautiful blessing
in your life sometimes coincidences are
great because we know we didn't create
them we were guided right yeah yeah yeah
so as you continue that with your eyes
closed breathing there yeah and ask
yourself about that situation but stay
breathing your heart stay in that same
feeling so you're in a beautiful state
and just ask yourself in that situation
all I need to remember is all you need
to focus on is all you need to do is
what in that situation that was
bothering me breathing in my heart
feeling the same beauty all you remember
is calling me to focus on is all I need
to believe all I need to do is what and
your heart knows the answer can you feel
it do you know the answer is appreciate
that I'm even in this position to even
have that as a dilemma yeah yeah and how
does that feel now when you think about
it it feels like gun rule number 31
retool yourself I always tell people the
most valuable lesson I got from my
mentor Jim Rohn was I asked my father
worked two jobs
we were always broke we had no money for
food and we lived in a community we
moved to it's just I thought they were
all rich and we're on the other side of
the tracks it was a lower middle class
but compared to where we live before
these people seem rich compared to us
I just didn't understand it and Jim said
to me Tony it's not about the value of
your soul it's about the value of you in
the marketplace and your father's skills
are not that valuable he used to take he
was underground parking attendant and he
would take people's ticket and make
change well the research now shows is
being done at Yale's being done overseas
in England as well and they found that
40% of all jobs they project in the next
10 years are going to disappear because
of Technology it's gonna be replaced by
an algorithm it's gonna be changed you
know all these guys on Wall Street
you're seeing all these algorithms take
over and they're getting rid of all
these traders right it's changing
radically these in these hedge funds
there's 3 million truck drivers
self-driving cars are here in the next 5
years they will be the standard
certainly within seven or eight years
are you gonna hire someone who can only
work eight hours a day and sometimes
gets drunk or could make a mistake when
you can buy a machine write down the
Machine and be in a position where it
works 24 hours a day driving but no one
is telling these drivers this and it's
they have to retool now so technology is
the biggest challenge labor is less
valuable because of efficiencies with
technology and it's gonna get that are
in better for technology which is scary
when you think about what's gonna happen
for jobs so I say to people you got to
participate in your own rescue
you've got to retool yourself the idea
of the Bernie Sanders has of providing
free education it sounds wonderful but
the education he wants to do is
Community College there are no skill
sets in Community College's today for
the most part that are gonna prepare you
for the economy or a job that's there so
what is that gonna do you're just gonna
waste more money more time we need to
retool ourselves the government's not
gonna do it for you
rule number 32 discipline your mind
these thoughts that we have we think
there are thoughts or makes it really
hard to change them people meditate
trying to not think possible show me
somebody has done that successfully
consistently the push everybody
the mind thinks thoughts but here's the
distinction if I told you a hundred
years ago we're gonna fly the moon and
back you would call me a lunatic that's
where the term comes from people still
use it it doesn't make any sense because
a lunatic for somebody thought we gotta
move back
right look I didn't know that yes but if
I would have told you a hundred years
ago that there's gonna be a box in your
pocket and you're gonna pull this thing
out you're gonna hit a couple buttons
and then it's gonna capture invisible
waves that are drifting around the earth
and bring the waves in and you're gonna
see somebody on the other side of the
earth and you're gonna talk to them
you're totally nuts thoughts are those
invisible waves and when you use your
body in a certain way if I sit like this
I'm gonna channel I'm gonna tap into a
different channel those waves that if
I'm sitting like this kinda like a TV
set if I turn one channel might be a
comedy channel I'm gonna see a lot of
laughter turn another one it's a horror
channel turn another channel it's a
romance channel this is what changes
which of those waves you touch in so if
you can start to realize that your cloth
do you think are your thoughts there's
nothing unique about your thoughts
they've been around for thousands of
years you're just tapping into them
because of what you're doing with your
body that makes you too fearful or
passion or too courageous or whatever
you're feeling as you go in those states
you get different thoughts so what I
want people to see is that learn how to
just see those thoughts go by it's
learning how to be entertained by those
thoughts cuz I have crazy thoughts then
but what I've got good at is going look
at that crazy thought
That's not me that's of a mind not your
mind cuz if it's you how do you change
you pretty hard but I really truly know
there's I haven't heard a thought come
out of you that's original you call them
your thoughts but they're not you've
stolen them Peyman around forever when
you see that it's easier to let go of
them and letting go of those thoughts is
one of the ways that you free yourself
and then again the more you do it just
like a muscle you get better and better
and better than all of a sudden they
used to make you crazy or stressed out
or make how many things you'd be worried
about then never came to be and some
people their life is good so they worry
about other people they're never not
worried right so it's really just a
pattern if you want wealth real wealth
is not just money it's emotion that's
like what are we really after in money
you know I'm buddy you want pieces of
paper with these pictures of deceased
notables on it you want we think money
will give you think it'll give you
freedom or security or stability or love
it won't give you a lot it'll get you
sex it won't get you lovin right so
really what
after is the emotion and so what I want
people to get is the emotion they want
now and all it is is a new habit it's
learning to discipline this mind right
by realizing the main thoughts are out
there and letting them float by and
constantly coming back to what can I
love about this what can I appreciate
it's like if you can learn to love or at
least appreciate start to enjoy the
things that used to get upset about how
much freedom would you have how much
more joy you dad and I know people got
billions of dollars I've coached them
who is like holy Sh they live in
scarcity all the time when man I'll
never forget he's screaming at his wife
I'm in the meat I mean I'm in the house
and he's screaming his wife because she
spent some money on a bunch of outfits
and stuff like that he's a
multi-billionaire he couldn't spend all
his money in his lifetime and then he's
totally upset at his daughters in her
20s who spent some money too and I'm
like I pulled of us afterwards and I
said what do you do this for and what do
you do it for it he's like well it's
just it's the principal thing I said no
the principal thing is do you love these
people and do you want them to have an
abundant life when you have you don't
have one loss but you live like you're
poor you know it's like I finally got
through them but so many people that's
why I say money doesn't change you money
magnifies who you are so you want to
expand the depth of who you are and free
yourself from suffering by just knowing
it's a pattern of thought and you can
change the pattern of all rule number 33
learn to execute you know you get on an
airplane what's the first thing they say
if we get into trouble masks will come
down oxygens there and the first thing
you got to do is put it on your kid
right no why they literally tell you to
put it on yourself you selfish bastard
what's the deal here right but it's
because we don't take care of ourselves
we can't tear them so for leaders when I
was telling this it's you first it
starts with you and it starts with your
psychology 80% of growing a business if
you look at what the chokehold is on our
business it's always the leader and 80%
of that chokehold is the psychology 20%
the mechanics I mean people in this room
know the mechanics and strategies beyond
what anybody on earth knows in their
category so it's really about you being
in the state where you execute it's like
I always tell people knowledge is not
power it's total BS knowledge is
potential power execution Trump's
knowledge every day of the week and some
of my life is how do you get to yourself
to execute an execution comes from
learning to put yourself in that right
state every day rule number 34 master
the skill of influence
I believe the leadership is really a
skill of influence is the most important
skill that any human being can master
and I don't think of leadership as a
position I see it as a skill a tool that
all of us have to have in other words
the quality of your life either really
believe comes down to your level of
leadership other people don't have to
follow you to be a leader but you have
to live life on your terms and the first
person you have to influence it yourself
you know whether you're fit or fat you
know whether your kids are out you know
on drugs or not it's who has more
influence the guy in the street corner
or you with your fitter fatness can you
influence your own hands your own body
your own mind to do what's necessary so
I think to be able to influence the
thoughts the feelings the emotions and
the actions of another human being
that's what leadership is rule number 35
build work-life integration
I believe in work-life integration I
don't think and I might be disrespectful
to oh no no yeah I'm saying everybody
has a different metaphor I'm telling my
metaphor I'm not making somebody wrong
focus my balance but to me if you say
balance it's like okay let's use a
teeter totter or a seesaw okay we're
gonna let's balance it now now that
we've done that how long are we gonna
stay in there balancing this thing
before one of us wants to jerk this
thing around just to feel alive right
yeah so I really think balance is is
more about integration for me it's more
about like how do I make sure that I
feel like the errors of my life my wife
my children my grandchildren my health
sports
I got 31 companies I got 1,200 employees
and seven radically different industries
we do five billion a year
I mean it's so all these things are
going on how do I do that well I believe
that the way I do that is the streaks
that he streaks of unbelievable
intensity work and I just reeks of like
let go and being you know paradise and
enjoy and so I like running high I wanna
I want to be an heavy climb in the
amount that's just me so I'm not saying
that's right for other people I'm saying
gotta find what it is but
idea of balance for most people makes
them torture themselves and I say it for
me if the torches should get rid of it
instead of saying talk about innovation
I asked Mary Callahan Erdos who's if
you're not familiar with her she's
probably the one of it's not the
smartest person in the financial world
female she's a head of JP Morgan and
manages 2.3 trillion with the team now
to be trillion dollars of the money
while the nicest human being ever me
breaks all the molds on people in the
financial business there's not an ounce
of manipulation in her body
I mean just good good soul and I asked
her about the balancing well the biggest
bank in the world right trillions of
dollars and she said Tony I don't
believe in it and she told me working on
felt external a for completing each
other's sentences she has the same
philosophy but her dad used to take her
to work and he was a financial guy when
she was a little girl she has to have
her brother be the secretary if things
she took her dad see Iran Michelle and
she said really Matt was my dad she goes
I loved it I was a part of this life I
got to be a part of to see that part of
his life then coming home and me not
knowing it and she said that's what
she's done with her kids in a JP Morgan
she leaves and picks her kids up and she
still runs the biggest thing the world
goes trillions of dollars so would she
say it's balance she'd say no it's not
bounce it's integrate she knows when to
move into one or the other right so that
all the parts of her life are rich maybe
instead of balance it's a rich life in
the areas that matter
yeah right rich with your children rich
with your husband or wife rich with your
dear friends rich with the impact that
you want to have your mission rich in
terms of successful business and or
whatever your career is that you really
feel a sense of meaning and enjoyment to
me that's more important than balance
that I think but I'm a very passionate
balance a little boring if you're
tortured by balance try to be balanced I
um people are not balanced enough give
it
instead enjoy yourself enjoy your
children enjoy the time be where you are
right now that to me is more important
than trying to make
in balance because that becomes negative
cerebral it makes you evaluate things a
more you evaluate the less you can
actually experience with you right now
rule number 36 give energy everything in
my world is based on coming up with the
outcome that will serve and then going
at it but most of the time your approach
going at it doesn't work no one else
knows that but you know you can see it
doesn't work so it's constantly changing
your approach until you can get where
you want to go and I enter an audience
and I'm gonna give a talk of any sort I
do a huge amount of homework in advance
I prepare as he is there but then when I
stand up here I wouldn't be sitting like
this I'm scanning constantly who I'm
looking for the people think it's bull
I'm going after the people who got
dragged there I'm not looking for the
people clapping for me you know that
those people will always be there and
there's some people clap even if you're
terrible so you don't want to other
people's view make you feel good I'm
looking for who isn't there so that I
can reach them so I can show them that
there's something real here because you
know most people don't know who I am
they'd see you know ten thousand people
jumping in a stadium and they got it's
just a big motivational pump up I've
never been a motivator it's never open
up what I've been about I think
motivation is useful is like a warm bath
you should probably take a bath or a
shower every day but you need more than
that you need strategy and but what I
really believe is the energy most of us
grew up and right now most of you are
learning and the traditional style you
did leave when you're at school you were
trained to go to your seat and be silent
and be polite and nice but the world we
live in today isn't like that the world
today if somebody sits down and waits
for someone tell them what to do they're
in trouble so my approach is constantly
stimulating and seeing what's real
getting people to be raw and getting to
truth you know as corny as it is the
truth sets us free and we all can find
our own truth as long as we put
ourselves in environment where we don't
tolerate anything less than that rule
number 37 learn how to lead I really
believe in order to influence people you
got to know what already influences them
huh the mistake that we make is we don't
connect enough to figure out who this
person is and what most of us do is try
to lead other people by influencing them
the way we'd be influenced they try to
influence their kid to clean the room
the way that would make you do it but
even though they're your kid they're
different than you and so they're gonna
do it for a different set of reasons
than what you would do it for you might
have done it because someone told you to
but your kids
all day long that's not it there has to
be something else it's a sense of
freedom they get from it or a sense of
mass just something that's going to move
them so I always say there are two
things that influence everyone if you
want to be a leader you have to know how
to change other people's states a person
is in a no state a person's in an angry
state persons in a frustrated state you
have to be able to influence their stake
is if you change their state you're
gonna change the result they get but the
second thing you have to understand is
what are people's blueprints blueprints
my shorthand for what are the values
what do they believe what do they fear I
always say to people then life is found
in the dance between what you desire
most and what you fear most if I want to
lead you and support you I got to know
your goals your desires I don't know
what you're scared about well you're
fearful about what stresses you out and
if I understand that I can communicate
in a way that'll inspire you to maximize
not only when I'm here that's management
leadership is ongoing and you've raised
your own standard and you're gonna
continue to perform at a higher level
rule number 38 change your story how to
do something is the wrong sequence to
start with like what's the strategy for
being fit and healthy it's not that
complex and yet 70% of the u.s. is
overweight like he doesn't have to do it
it's not a strategy problem but it is is
why are they doing it it's because they
have a story and everyone does is
entrepreneurs business people everyone
does this when we get fearful when we've
tried something that we're not
succeeding as fast as we want when we
are afraid of failing we come up with a
story about how it's not our fault or
how we're gonna do it in the future
because they don't have to feel bad
feeling bad makes us have to deal with
it most people are overwhelmed so they
just they come up with a story that I
tried everything if you tried everything
you'd be fit you know I tried million
things Williams name of three things
they did many times that don't work but
I think if you can come up when you
change the story when you come up with a
new set of beliefs you'll find yourself
finding the strategy or using the
strategies that already work that are
there that right now your mind says are
won't work and the best way to change
people you got strategy story is state
and I only share this with this
got to be able to produce a different
state of your people there has to be
something compelling there has to be a
sense of mission
rule number 39 get feedback how do you
get better how do you know listen I was
good today but I want to be great what
are the metrics you use I mean is there
data you get back how do you improve
well we have all the social media data
which we we use big data take a look at
but I also look at it individually
because there's nuances that you pick up
in that way so I feed that look at that
but my biggest piece is watching the
audience and then you know every day of
my life I get feedback and walking down
the street a dozen people come and tell
me these beautiful stories that their
life has changed and very much like like
she shared earlier they'll give me way
too much credit so I always straight go
look you did this I'm glad I got the
help and I try to keep that balance with
everybody but my measurement is both
emotional state impact as well as
execution did they lose 20 pounds did
they go turn their business around you
know my business is organized around I
really want to help people improve all
the qualities the areas of their life
but there's about seven that matter the
most it's your body it's your emotions
that your relationships it's the way you
manage time its finances it's your work
and it's the spiritual side of life and
so what I spent my life doing is
modeling people that are the best world
you find a couple have been together for
65 years in their 80s late eighties and
they're still making love and passionate
not just hanging out they're not lucky
they're doing something different so I'm
constantly finding those patterns so
that hopefully I can compress the
decades in today's I can learn from
those decades of life experience say
that bring the answer here to myself and
others and see a measurable impact rule
number 40 find happiness and when you're
in a negative state you don't perform at
a higher level when you're in a negative
state it affects your biochemistry if
that commute system you're in a negative
state affects the people around you when
you're in a great state perform better
enjoy life more greater impact all the
above so it's intelligent to be in a
peak thing but you know you only can
manage what you measure like a business
you know if I when I take company over
turn around start measuring things and I
measure the most important things and
the more you measure the better we'll
get because you get more instead of
managing once a year if you're measuring
once a week you got 52 times to improve
it versus one so I started measuring and
I said I'm gonna live in a beautiful
state no matter what everyday now in
order to do that I have to do two things
a I have to acknowledge that I've been
suffering and I need to figure out what
my favorite flavor of suffering it and I
played off of that with myself and I
thought frustrated and pissed on for
free.you separately in fact I realized
that my happiness was so cheap cause all
I needed was this thing and I could lose
my happiness because ding something cool
or games something not so cool you got
1200 poise what are the chances right
now that one of them is doing something
to screw up Hey
not consciously they're just not doing
what they're supposed to do basically a
100 percent chance and if I was near
this I get triggered my god am i
happiness to disappear so what it again
say is I'm going to be happy even if
they screw up I'm gonna be happy in me
they lost the million bucks I want to be
happy like if I happiness is depend upon
other people behaving a certain way the
way I want them to I'm pretty
influential guy but I'm not God and
everybody's got their own things that
they're doing
I'm never gonna stay happy and if I have
to even make my heaviness based on me
behaving a perfect way every moments not
gonna happen
so I gave room for life and I decided to
make a real decision that's my
invitation to people and then I'll
answer your question hi now first you
got to make the decision that says life
is too short to suffer I mean I don't
know it's gonna happen in your lifetime
with your children with your wife with
your economics your business I'm sure
you do well everything but there's
things outside our control the
government could change the rules on
something right the rules have changed
before around like marketing and so
forth um you're somebody your family
could get very ill someone can die in
our families right no more talk about it
but can happen if you're happy this is
only gonna be when everything matches
how you think it should be you're not
going to be there and my view is that
there's power it happens we downplay in
this culture
when the person is happy they attract
other people when a person is happy they
live longer that's a fact well people
are happier they earn more right they do
better in their careers I mean these are
physiological these are measured facts
in our society and yet we poopoo
happiness in our well by God's being
enthusiastic or something like that
no it's being inspired in spirit healing
oh I so what I did was is as much energy
or passion I had before I still had that
but what I found was what was the stuff
that would suck away that energy and so
now to answer your question how would I
know
number one I put the line listened and
said these are the ones I tend to drop
into I'm not doing anymore and if I find
it I didn't rule I got 90 seconds to get
out at 90 second rule that should have
been the for our world but uncertain
things every 90 seconds reason certainly
to get hook totally that was like for a
tree before Dave Ruel example of
initially but as I did it more and more
it's like a muscle and when you use the
muscle over and over again it works it's
their treat and so how I known an
special already discussion but without
that I think people are sad we're
talking about is I sense tension in my
body like when you're in a beautiful
state things flow when there's a tension
you can feel it in your face yet
somebody says something somebody is them
somebody didn't do something already use
a certain term somebody you brought
something out or you did something you
should have done whenever that happens
there's a tension and so I'd really
train myself to feel that tension and
when I feel I go 90 seconds and it's a
game now 90 seconds and since I value
that happening so much not like a
deluded person now I'm so happy like I
value being in a beautiful state because
it may not be happy it may be driven it
may be courageous
it may be feeling bold it may be love it
may be compassion for someone else or
even myself right Alan I can't always
have compassion by other people or never
for myself ray and so what I began to do
is realize holy cow this is something
that could change everything
and so that $0.90 row I feel the tension
here's what I do I know that it's
triggered by one of three language
patterns as a trigger as an example lost
less than ever if you perceive that
something someone you're counting on
they failed to do something that it
failed the sale something say something
or or you fail to do something or say
something you should have then what
happens as that tension starts to show
up because your brain goes I lost that
opportunity I lost this moment I lost
that respect I lost this love I lost the
money I lost whatever you thought your
loss and loss is always an illusion
there's like the next opportunity
two minutes around the corner you know
it's not that complexity if we look for
it if you find it if we don't live in
the illusion of loss or less as the next
one if you think's because he or she did
something or didn't do it you have less
of something you value less love less
joy less excitement less time less
energy less economics less respect
you're gonna suffer inside you know some
people suffer by being angry some people
suffer by feeling sad everyone has
different flavors right right you're
gonna suffer and the worst one is never
if you think because she or he did this
or Donald Trump did something or didn't
do it or Mary Sue or youself didn't do
it and now you'll never have that love
you'll never have that respect you'll
never have that joy you'll never have
that economics what you believe that
stuff then the suffering stays so the
way out of Los West never is always
appreciation or gratitude or love
rule number 41 change your psychology if
you look at a business the choke hold on
the growth of any business is always the
psychology and the skill set of a leader
and it's 80% psychology and 20%
mechanics meaning so many small
businesses you know the owner might be
an incredible innovator
maybe they write incredible code maybe
they're a tremendous influencer but they
don't know the economic side of their
business right and they find themselves
getting in trouble because somebody's
giving them financial information after
the fact they don't have true financial
intelligence to make decisions and they
get caught up can you can you give me an
example of a business like that you have
to name names no I got this I'll pick my
own examples I had several companies or
my career that we're near bankruptcy
because I would sit down and I would I
knew how to produce products that would
change people's lives I knew how to
market I knew that I building teams of
people but what I didn't know was
finding it so I'd look and say you know
okay what are we doing it oh you got a
great you know you got a 20% profit you
know you got two million dollars in
profit those day little tiny company and
I've come to the end of the year there
was no cash right I didn't know that
profit is a theory you know and so just
not having that skill or someone might
be really great in finance but they're
not any good in marketing so sometimes
it's a skill problem but 80% of it you
can solve those skills you can get those
skills if you can change your psychology
but when you accept that oh my god the
markets down or oh my god the economy an
area is down when you allow the
environment to control your psychology
you're not gonna win
rule number 42 find fulfillment also my
goal of the book is really for people to
be happy and more fulfilled because you
got a ton of money and still being
miserable right you know so it's it's
really it's it's like mastering the
science of achievement but also the art
of fulfillment it's about if you're
totally successfully you're not
fulfilled then what do you get nothing
you know you made everybody happy but
yourself you know that's the worst thing
you got that that's Robin Williams is a
beautiful man so it's a beautiful man
killed himself right and he keyed
everything most people have a dream
about a beautiful family you've made the
whole world laugh hundreds of million
people loved him but he didn't figure
out how to end the suffering money won't
do that
rule number 43 understand business most
entrepreneurs are artists in their
nature look at three types of
personalities and artists to somebody
that has a tremendous gift a skill and
ability a talent you know like an
athlete you know Curry's and as in the
advanced incredible artists some people
they're artists sales they can sell ice
to an Eskimo some people it's writing
software they're incredible we're
designing clothes and most businesses
are started by an artist who says I can
do it better but they don't realize that
as you start to try to grow a business
and you're the most talented employee
the beginning of the cheapest one right
yeah and now you hire other people and
you know they're not going to do as good
a job and it ties people into this
negative effect what I really see is the
biggest mistake that these individuals
make is they don't understand business
they get in because they want to do good
work for their client and most of them
as you know ninety-six percent are gone
in ten years and the four percent that
survived but they aren't necessarily
profitable I mean five percent of all
businesses ever crapped a million
dollars are gross not that profitability
gross and you know point zero zero zero
six so it's six one hundred six out of a
hundred thousand businesses will ever do
ten million gross so I say to people in
the business I never encourage people to
get a business I try to push them away
because it's too hard if you don't have
the internal drive to make it through
that psychologically you're better
partnering with somebody you're better
doing something else
I think under a stay in business is the
challenge I always say that 80% of the
choke hold on the growth of any business
is always the owner the leader and
eighty percent of that is their
psychology than 20% of skills like if
you don't market you're in trouble
most most entrepreneurs get in trouble
because they don't know how to read
their financials they don't have a clue
I invited you know it's like you can go
out on a plane on a day like today
that's a decent day and you can fly if
you're a pilot with what they call
visual flying world so you can loop it
around you need a flight you get it a
storm you better be able to read those
instruments are you gonna die and most
entrepreneurs know how to read those
instruments they look down and they see
profit loss and they know I made a
profit or I'm gonna lost they have a
beer either right wanted to drown out
the pain again I want to celebrate right
and problem is a theory is you know
accounting is a very special language
unless you understand how to use
accounting to make better decisions so
you learn understand and measure things
in a way that gives you better
decision-making capability then you get
broadsided and you know
profitability you get a lot of profit no
cash so I think not understand the full
aspect of the business not managing your
own psychology and not knowing your
we'll be three critical things that I
think sabotage most businesses rule
number 44 constantly improve yourself
hey can you don't have a standard
education and expect to have an
extraordinary life it's not gonna happen
the one breakthrough for all leaders is
constant never-ending improvement and
that means educating yourself and
continuing to develop even greater
emotional mastery because that's what
affects whether you execute enough the
opportunity for self education is there
we have to change our psychology firm
I'm gonna do what everybody else does
and I'm mad because it doesn't work
anymore - the reality is this the
greatest time to be alive if you're
growing you're learning you're educating
and you're developing valuable skills so
instead of complaining you gotta say
where are the skill sets valued in the
marketplace and how do I work harder on
myself
than anything else because if I become
more valuable then I will be able to
give more do more and change more my
interview Warren Buffett asks the most
important investment he ever made in his
life you already said it was I was
thinking all the companies they've done
you know he said Tony going to Dale
Carnegie said what he goes because by
developing myself that's the most
important investment those skill sets
learning how to persuade learning how to
speak learning and influence all my
ideas would've died on my lips if I
hadn't be able to influence and I
learned it from that little course most
valuable thing I ever did in my life he
said rule number 45 change your patterns
I physically stressed my body to
extremes because I've developed a
process that take people and help them
change you know in a weekend but my idea
of the weekend is 50 hours and most
people once set for a three-hour movie
so you know and somebody since spent 300
million dollars on and I got 12,000
people in a stadium I got back from last
night up in San Jose we had for days and
nights like this and we actually had a
halter on me and a group of researchers
that work with Olympic athletes and I've
burned 9,500 calories in one day in nine
hours the battery died before I finished
I had I went 12 hours I did I burned
enough calories for two marathons my
jumps because I'm jumping constantly was
the equivalent of two NBA games my
lactate as you all know that one is hard
to talk it was 14 and I was still going
strong at 12 hours so there's some
physical stress because
I'm a believer that talking is both that
you got to go deep you got to get people
to experience things I think a belief is
a poor substitute for an experience and
I got someone experience changing
something I can do it a really potent
way where they really feel it
then you know if you do that over and
again you start to get someone to
actually be trained to get a new result
it's not about belief
you know belief is important it's not
about confidence I heard that kind of
description there's never blue it's
about its strategy but if you don't have
the certainty you're not gonna execute
so I think I've spent a lifetime
accumulating patterns and our patterns
we all have their patterns and make your
angry patterns and make you sad patterns
make you excited patterns that make you
grateful patterns and health as you well
know so I look like all of you who are
the best of what you do I'm massively
into pattern recognition pattern
utilization and pattern creation and
those things help me to create changes
that wouldn't have happened before
rule number 46 live your mission people
talk about work for quite a balance I
was talking to Mary Calvin Erdos who's
an organization now she manages two
point six trillion with the T dollars
probably the most influential woman in
the financial world brilliant woman and
I asked her because you know I was
earning fifty of the smartest financial
people on the face of the earth I said I
know you're very deeply caring my mom
and your wife and how do you bailed on
it and she said Tony she because I made
this move your book she wrote it but
because there is no such thing as
work-life balance or something work-life
integration and I really believe that in
my soul so in my companies you know my
wife and I we live our mission together
we're 24/7 365 together and we love it
because we're driven by the same things
one of my son's is a partner and several
of my financial businesses one of my
other sons is in the coaching business
you know my daughter's an actress and
you know totally different business but
she cares for people the same way so
there's a common denominator within our
family
we're also mission driven that we don't
have to separate the two when your
family's involved involved in your
mission
you're not pulled apart you're pulled
together the same
I think the hard part is so many
families have totally different wives
and they come together when they're
exhausted and try to have a relationship
together and I think that's really hard
for people today I always encourage
people to say listen in in your
partnership in life you want to find
somebody who's your best friend because
intimacy and passion is easy to turn on
but friendship is not and if you have a
friend who shares your values and your
mission and if you're privileged enough
to do things together as a business
owner I find that to be the greatest
possibility of that work-life
integration rule number 47 hustle I
always tell people I said tell me tell
me in your schedule no go well you know
I go to work and I work 9:00 to 5:00 and
I come home I'm exhausted and so you
know what am I gonna start a business I
said well what about the other
eight-hour shift cuz that's what I did
right I had to be able to work from 8:00
to 5:00 in a normal job and then I start
working as a janitor cuz I work my own
hours the middle of the night but I
worked 8:00 to 5:00 and literally I'd
come home I get a bite to eat and I'd
start my work at 6:00 p.m. 6:30 p.m. and
I go from 6:30 to 2:00 a.m. and I'd get
another 17 hours in and that's how I
built everything in the beginning that's
honestly what's required and to not do
that is to cheat yourself because in the
end what we get will never make us happy
I don't care how many stars on your
chart how many Academy Awards how much
money you make what makes us happiest
progress progress equals happiness if
you're not growing you're dying inside
rule number 48 survive hardships when I
was growing up I went through a really
tough childhood my mom was a beautiful
soul but she abused prescription drugs
and alcohol and because people have
different personalities in that area and
she would I'm the oldest I've younger
brother five younger sister seven years
younger and she bashed my head against
the wall she think I was lying and she
pulled liquid soap down my throat till I
threw up it was pretty brutal but it
made me become a practical psychologist
it may may have to learn what makes
people get crazy get angry get excited
yet love and I had to learn how to
manage her to protect my brother and
sister and then to some extent myself
and so you know my mom had been the
woman I'd hope she'd been I wouldn't be
the man I'm proud to be so it all worked
out in a very beautiful way but it made
me I had so much suffering in my life I
don't want any human to suffer and
I'm f and driven to end suffering
wherever I can possibly make a
difference I don't want to sin suffering
I want them to experience the joy and
the happiness and the freedom and the
love and the opportunity to live life on
their terms but do you have to fail to
be successful you have to have suffering
to be successful well you have to fail I
don't know if you have suffer you know
the old phrase you know pain is part of
life suffering is a choice right rule
number 49 get financially free what
should we as business owners and
professional business owners what should
we never give up on well I think I
figured to decide what's most important
to you and what are you doing all this
for you're just doing it for money it's
a burn out for anything so you got to
just ask yourself what you want to give
up on is why'd you get the business
originally what is it you really want an
economic freedom should be clearly one
of those things for people but time
freedom should be there also that's why
I work with Dennis they go to business
mastery to make him an owner so think
it's Ted to say you know I really could
have somebody else in some of these
taking over some of these clients and
most are scared to do that initially
because I go that's my income we show
them how to time it so they gradually
even up getting more income from other
people working than yourself then you do
your best work you know it's like the
goal is get ffunny actually free not so
you never work again cuz if you don't
have work and you dry up inside you know
that's like when I was growing up
everybody's like making the money to get
rich and retire so I did that at 26
which is food oh sure and the amount of
money I had I thought was more than you
could spend of course that was not true
but what I learned is it's really about
making it money you don't ever have to
work together than you work harder than
you enjoy more you know Steve Wynn's a
different I'm I don't you know most of
Las Vegas and you any sweat 74 Peter
Guber who's here now a friend of mine
owns the Warriors and Los Angeles
Dodgers
you know it's movie companies you know
74 years old works does more today than
what I knew when he was 50 or Buffett
eight was 84 85 now works harder today
Livermore know those people have to work
they do it because it's so fulfilling
but it's different when you don't have
to work and you work then you have to
work in your work it's like a different
being and real number 50 the last one
before a very special bonus rule is use
the power of compounding
I'm pleased golf in this room anybody
play golf so if I said to you let's go
play golf and by the way I'm a terrible
golfer I never play and shook the island
play at six eight holes I just got for
some fun a little bit with my wife and
friends and as we're walking along I
tell you that but as we get up to the
first hole I say you know just to make
it a little more interesting why don't
we bet a dime a hole just so there's
something on the line now most people
are gonna go no problem they're gonna go
you know see a shark as he set me up
ten cents oh how many holes are there 18
holes how much I got at risk a buck 80
right okay not a big deal and then I'm
just about to get up there and hit the
first ball and I see them just make it a
little more interesting why don't we
just double it each hole so what would
that be first well it's 10 cents the
second hole is 20 cents third hole would
be 40 cents fourth hole is gonna be 80
cents fitful is gonna be bucks if these
six holes gonna be three twenty now stop
how many holes are there 18 so we're one
third the way through and it's three
dollars and 20 cents so in your head you
say well you know so what might cost me
10 12 15 bucks if I lose no big deal but
if we continue the math what happens
let's take it out to nine holes and see
what is nine holes get up tonight holes
we go wow I wasn't expecting $25 but
we're only halfway there go ahead flip
the balance 11 12 now look what happens
here we get to the 13th hole four to
nine dollars we went from down here
twenty-five bucks 400 away or worth four
hundred nine how do we go from 25 to 404
holes
power of compounding watch what happens
these last holes 14th or 15th or 16th
17th 18th hole 13100 $7 ok so if you're
a good golfer this is what you'll go do
next for next week when you get home
right now I've got a really special
bonus gift from Tony on how to know who
you are that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from watching another video to
actually taking action
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what do you need to
execute on this week number two who can
you ask her feedback on your plans and
number three what do you need to stay
more disciplined on
every one of your readers or viewers if
in this case should really ask themself
the question Who am I am i corps because
we all have different gifts that we can
get and business I think you know other
than love your labor is probably the
most sacred gift you can give any human
being because it's so much of your time
your energy it's the essence of all
you've developed in your life if you
look at it there's three gifts you could
give there's the gift of a specific art
a skillset an ability a talent that you
have and many people are artists they're
not just artists like they paint they
have something that they're just so good
at and then they start a business
because they go you know what I can
design better clothing than the person I
work for I can write better code of
course running a business is more than
just the art of it right and most
businesses are started by an artist and
those businesses you know fail so if you
look at that you'd say if I'm an artist
I'm a struggle because I'm going to want
to do my art a great business person
says it doesn't matter what I care about
I can't fall in love my product or
service I need to fall in love with my
client and I got a constantly-changing
to meet their needs don't fall in love
with your product or service fall in
love with your ideal client that's a
different game there's another type of
person who's more of a manager leader
meaning their gift is not a specific
skill set like selling or creating or
something it's managing people and
processes and they love it right and
it's their nature when it's your nature
you tend to get good at it if you work
at it right cuz it's just who you are
you're reinforced for it and then
there's the entrepreneur and every
somebody calls himself an entrepreneur
but there are people that are
entrepreneurial and they're
entrepreneurs and an entrepreneur by
nature is different they love risk they
live risk it's like Steve Wynn's dear
friend of mine and he took me to cow and
I saw this guy loose 30 no 10 million
dollar excuse me in less than 30 minutes
and the guy got up and gave Steve a hug
and said all mister win you're
incredible he actually said would you
take a picture and I'm used to hearing
this right side so sure he goes oh you
got a picture of me with mr. Wynn he
just lost ten billion dollars forever
right that guy's
entrepreneur he loses ten million I'll
just figure another way to earn it again
right it's a different mindset an
entrepreneurs in it for the money right
there might be for other things too but
they do want to make money the artist is
not as committed to make you money they
want to make money but they want to do
their art they want to make that dress
they want to write that code they want
to do what they love so if you're gonna
be a successful businessperson
economically you gotta say Who am I and
who do I need if I'm a great artist I
probably need a good manager leader as a
partner because they're gonna help me
build the organization and I can still
do the art that people love and I'm
gonna just make sure my art is what they
want that's just what I want if I'm
gonna grow and scale Who am I if I'm a
manager leader I might want to tie in
with a great entrepreneur because
there's gonna be something much greater
I can be a part of it own a piece of
potentially if I'm their final mantra
nor I'm looking for great artists cuz
they're gonna be the core of my business
I'm looking great manager leaders so you
got to know who you are and who you need
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that passion not one
drop of most self-worth depends on your
acceptance of an if you want more Tony
check out the video we did on him on how
to deal with stress and depression the
link is right there next to me I think
you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there you've
identified that as the way that you live
you've actually I always tell people you
get what you tolerate
[Music]